これよく見るとおもいます。早押し！アンサー
これ早押しアンサーって言うんの
ま、なんかクソガキがピンポンとやってますね
これめちゃ見ると思いますし
YouTubeでもよくこれを使われるんですけども
クイズ番組とかでも
こう、問題がでて答えるときに
てよくやると思うんですけども
僕ふと思ったんですよ
これ電池で動いているわけじゃないすか
これほら押してさ
？マーク出てますw
自信ないのかなぁ
赤いボタンを押すと
ピンポン鳴るやつがあるんですけども
もし！
大切な場面で壊れたらどうしますか？
強めに押す人もいると思うんで
これ自体の電池面
このバネ面、ボタン面
今鼻で笑っただろw
１回目
これ静岡帰れなくなりますよ？
やや俺はぜってぇ壊してから帰るから
１００回いきましたが
まだ全然元気そうと思います
どんどんいきましょう
音がちょっとね
もうちょい頑張ってみましょう
これやっっば～いなぁ
さあここから私が実況していきましょう
すいません、ボタンを押すだけで
とてもつまらない動画になっておりますっ
さあ手が速い手が速いおっと！
分身している手が分身している！
痛そうですね
さあどんどん押していきましょう
bレッドブルを飲みながらやっていく手が速い
すごい手が分身している
見ろ！これ！彼の手が
４つ、５つ、いや６つ！
手が分身しているように見えていますが
これは早送りのせいです
すごいですねでも
果たして何回目で
正解ピンポンボタンは壊れるのでしょうか
まるで阿修羅像のごとく
手が分身している
すごい！卓球か！卓球をしているのかお前は！
ラリーが続く、まさにピンポンだー！
２０００回いって大きな変化といえば
ないっすね～
２０００回超えてきたので正直言いましょう
とてもしんどくなってきましたが
ナン
頑張ってるからもうちょっと見てくれや(^^)
さあ眠そうな２人、もうすぐ３０００回だ
果てしないぜまだまだいくぜ⤴
この後どこまで伸びるのか
おっと２人とも顔の表情が硬いぞ
無機質な表情になっていますが
手は止めない
大連打をしているが
２人の顔はまったく面白そうではありません
さあどんどん数字を伸ばしてやがて4000になるぅか
これはやっていて楽しいのか！
おっと言ってはいけないことを言ってしまった
この後はついに５０００回というわけでございますが
もうボタンの叩き方が完全にプロとなっていますね
この両手打ち！両手打ちがすごい速い
交互に打って手が痛いようですが
こっち見んなっていう感じですが
手は速い！
５０００回いった！
これ壊れないんじゃね？
みたいな空気が漂っているんですけども
とりあえずは
さあ両手打ちが止まらない
この動きはまるでドンキーコンガ
おっと目が痒い
たなっちも目が痒い
さあ8000後半でございます
やがて9000代になりますが
どうだ２人の表情は
１つも嬉しそうではない！
このままどんどん叩いていくと
数字はついに9999
カンストしてしまう
果たして彼らを待ち受けているのは栄光か
それとも
地獄かー！
これ以上やっても意味がないだって！
９９９９回もクイズ大会することないもん一生！
ないも～～ん！